lined up in their thousands East Timor
is proud of its democracy with more than
80 percent of the population registered
to vote
just look at the capital city Dilly it's
difficult to get electricity and clean
water the party I choose must fix the
roads electricity and provide clean
water that is what I want from the new
government
the winning party must work with other
parties for the next government no one
can claim the victory by themselves
everyone must work together to build
this nation for the good of the people
17 parties are contesting the selection
the National Congress for T Marie's
reconstruction is led by janana guzmao
who was a rebel commander during the
Indonesian occupational he's trying to
push the country's oldest party fretlein
out of government and is challenging
fellow freedom fighter and current prime
minister Mari alcatiri the two were
allies in the struggle for Independence
now their political rivals that group of
leaders is very important to turmery's
uh uh but they are approaching 80.
shanana will be 80 in a few years and
the others are not far behind him so
this is a really critical election
because it's likely to be the one in
which there's a political transition to
a younger generation
this is the fifth parliamentary election
since East Timor gained independence
from Indonesia in 2002. important issues
for voters include the economy which is
heavily dependent on oil and gas as well
as securing new income from tourism and
agriculture guzmao says the solution
lies in the greater Sunrise exploration
project located between East Timor and
Australia but it's been stalled for
years over negotiations on where to
process the gas
the Region's going to be keeping an eye
on the election because of the
implications it holds for the greater
Sunrise hydrocarbon field in its
development which is located off the
south coast of the country and
timor-lestein needs for an investment to
develop that field the youth vote is
expected to determine the winner with 75
of the voting population younger than
35. if there's no outright majority the
party with the most votes will have to
negotiate with smaller parties to form a
coalition that could take weeks Sarah
Clark Al Jazeera